troisième sujet ce soir écoutons écouté
jacques dorcel patron de twitter pour
nous dit il il n'est pas crédible de
dire nous travaillons dur pour empêcher
les gens de contourner les règles de nos
systèmes en diffusant des informations
fausses mais si quelqu'un nous paye pour
forcer les gens à voir leur publicité
politique
alors ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils veulent
si on paye alors on peut tout dire c'est
manifestement en tout cas l'avis de marc
zuckerberg
bon écoute alors daniel bilalian vous
êtes plutôt zuckerberg ou plutôt d'orsay
alors que moi je suis je suis je suis
épouvanté par la puissance que peuvent
avoir des personnages comme zuckerberg
et les gaffes à angers qui peuvent qui
peuvent répondre ça un député qui peut
se passer au dessus des lois regarder
sur la publicité en général on a fait
une loi en france monsieur maire a fait
une loi et l'autriche veut pas grossier
mais vous là c'est à peu près ça et là
c'est pareil
ces personnages là sont andorre ont plus
ce qui fait peur c'est qu'ils ont plus
de pouvoir aujourd'hui que les hommes
politiques surtout ceux qui font les
lois internationales et noah il ya plus
de loi ils font ce qu'ils veulent et
c'est ça qui m'épouvante dans sa réponse
il est un peu gêné comme ça aux
entournures mais on sent très bien que
il en a rien à fiche de ce qu'elle lui
marc landré
pensez donc je suis bien content d'être
sur twitter et sur facebook
c'est une forme de réponse disons que ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir le
choix économiques effet parce que
twitter en refusant de diffuser des ddd
publicité politique en pleine année les
présidentielles aux états unis ça va
être un manque à gagner terrible pour
twitter mais donne ce côté lui a dit il
va être tranquille qui va pas voir dans
mes conseillers à la lettre en revanche
oui mais il assume en revanche il va
être tranquille parce que comme ça ses
salariés vont pouvoir dormir
tranquillement il va pas avoir de
campagne de campagne de communication
contre lui al'inverse de facebook qui
lui va engranger des profits records
parce qu'il diffusera à prix d'or est
encore plus l'année prochaine parce
qu'on se rende un électorale faut il
rappeler que 2020 celles des années
l'élection présidentielle aux états unis
et par contre ça va être un calvaire
pour ces équipes et pour lui même
parce qu'effectivement on aura tout et
son contraire qui seront diffusées sur
facebook
donc c'est avant tout aussi un choix
économique que courageux de la part du
patron de twitter contre celui de
facebook latine est la différence entre
un spot publicitaire pour une dans les
campagnes électorales en france passe
donc la télévision ou des spots pour le
parti socialiste les républicains
quelle est la différence entre officiels
ils sont validés alors alors alors que
la voilà alors est-ce qu'il n'y aurait
pas injustement suppose la question pour
ça est ce qui aurait pas un moyen pour
ces entreprises de l'hymne de les faire
valider parce que s'il n'y a pas de
raison qu'on puisse pas faire de
publicité ou de propagande que vous
voulez à partir du mans elle est validée
par une instance de nice comme c'est le
cas avec art et science qu'à trois mois
avant les élections en france il y avait
des ailes aux etats unis c'est
anticonstitutionnel
parce que la liberté d'expression fait
que l'on peut dire tout et n'importe
quoi sous couvert du cinquième à ne pas
twitter aujourd'hui mais les réseaux se
pose ne refuse de trier les contenus une
responsabilité qu'il refuse et c'est
d'une grande différence avec les médias
c'est qui est responsable de ce conte de
ce collectif le font le tri des contenus
fin en fait cette histoire est tous des
fondamentale elle se pose la question ou
pas oui elle pose la question d'un mais
dans tous les cas il dit wait see
et de sa pose la question de la façon
dont on crée aujourd'hui le débat
démocratique
je crois que les sondages qui montrent
que 50 à 60 % des ménages américains les
adultes américains se renseigner d'abord
via les réseaux sociaux qu'il faut
comprendre que le nouveau moyen de 2
pourrait dire de débat possible
aujourd'hui c'est via ses réseaux
sociaux qu'on le veuille ou non que les
médias traditionnels ont perdu beaucoup
de leur aura et en tout cas complètement
leur côté absolument exclusive donc
aujourd'hui vous avez une puissance
objectif de ces de ces réseaux sociaux
et ils sont pris on pourrait dire entre
deux entre deux impossibilités ils ont
une injonction contradictoire soit il
refuse à ce moment là on dit abbas et là
c'est la censure se dire soyez soit il
refuse qu'on diffuse certains contenus
soit au contraire ils acceptent qu'ils
ont dit a et vous produisez les faits
que nous dans tous les cas ce qui est
cet astre autour du lycée ne pas parler
de tous les contenus parce que là on
parle des contenus publicitaires alors
ces cas pour les publicités mais c'est
le cas pour d'autres choses aussi mais
justement aurait pu avoir de l'argent
oui mais certes mais ils peuvent aussi
s'y ajoutent ils peuvent alterner ce qui
les landes mais il faut relier ça
aujourd'hui aussi à la question de la
censure et du de ce qu'on appelle la
curation des contenus aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont obligés de faire et que les états
leur demande de faire justement au nom
du respect va de les lois qu'on a qu'on
peut avoir chez nous qu'on adore faire
des lois non contre la liberté
d'expression c'est marrant on est sorti
avec le pays des libertés mais alors la
liberté d'expression en france alors là
c'est un truc ça nous paraît on rigole
les américains ont ils ont droit de tout
dire les habits les imbéciles
personnellement ça me paraîtrait normal
et dès qu'on commence à dire une chose
ne peut pas être dit si tu n'es si une
erreur ne peut plus être dit
malheureusement il devient plus
intéressante elle devient quasiment une
sorte de vérité cachée pour beaucoup de
gens et à mon avis et c'est bien plus
catastrophiques
aujourd'hui il s'est dit dans les faits
mécanisme est différent dans les fêtes
ce sont les réseaux sociaux qui
aujourd'hui décide de ce qui est vrai de
ce qui est faux ce qui est montré
problème de ce qui est caché et la
grande peur le grand problème qui est
derrière cette question en fait c'est
que de toute façon la fabrique du
consentement la fabrique de l'opinion
elle a perdu elle n'est plus dans les
mains des médias yannick plus dans les
mains des gouvernements
elle est dans les mains de barbus
berg et compagnie qui peuvent décider
d'imposer à peu près les idées qu'ils
veulent le problème fondamental il a il
est là et une partie d'explosion
démographique qu'on voit aujourd'hui
vient dans le fait qu'on n'a pas trouvé
la réponse
on n'a pas trouvé les modalités alors on
a fait en france on a voulu faire une
loi sur
vous pouvez interdire les mensonges
moment des au moment des campagnes
électorales on voit très très bien qu'on
n'a pas de réglementation n'a pas de
régulation haddock
parce que les outils sont tellement
puissants et c'était la monétique est
interdite pendant les campagnes
oui mais en période de campagne mais
robin la publicité politique c'est un
spot mais quand j'ai vingt mille
followers 50000 fowler un million de
followers et que je fais un tweet ou je
donne mon avis ou jeu où je donne un
fait n'importe quel cas mercialys et
c'est pas parce commercial mais c'est
une publicité politique je peux vous
dire qu'il ya beaucoup plus d'impact à
la réalité quand même cédé ça va bien un
autre camp qui diffuse va bien une
fausse information
le premier qui sont rémunérés fausses
informations ils seraient de toute façon
d'être justes mais juste un truc moi ce
qui m'a ce qui m'a énormément choqué
lors des dernières présidentielles aux
états unis pourtant je suis vraiment pas
un spécialiste des élections américaines
c'est lorsque facebook a vécu les une
information comme quoi il y avait des
esclaves qui étaient utilisés dans les
cuisines d'un restaurant à new york qui
était propriété d'hillary clinton
voilà il c'est devenu un fait c'est
devenu un fait une information de
campagne aux états unis et qui a coûté
des voix et des clinton et ça ça lui
fait que news qui a été véhiculée par le
camp républicain
et c'est pas normal c'est quand même la
confirmation sur internet beaucoup de
gens qui n'avaient rien à dire le ferons
savoir
dans mon peu quand même ceux d'abord moi
je me félicite de la décision du patron
de twitter je suis pas du tout dans une
naïveté
concernant twitter 20 ça on l'a bien
d'autres problèmes à régler sur les
contenus qui sont diffusées hors
publicité politique sur twitter et qui
parfois ne sont pas interdits alors
qu'ils le devraient
sur les alertes qui seront faits sur
certains comptes et qui ne sont pas
interdits bref on est sûrs en gros le
rôle de twitter aujourd'hui dans la
fabrique de l'opinion on pourrait bien
sûr posé plein d'autres questions mais
je trouve que cette décision est plutôt
est plutôt intéressante
en revanche elle ne règle rien elle
règle est effectivement la pilule à la
question des publicités politiques mais
on sait que tout le reste revient sur
twitter ce n'est pas un cas sur facebook
et quand on sait que déjà sur facebook
on avait un problème hors publicité
politique avec notamment le fait
qu'aujourd'hui les algorithmes cible des
personnes c'est à dire que vous avez un
contenu que vous regardez on vous
propose d'autres contenus qui sont en
rapport et à la fin
la fabrique de l'opinion peut se faire
par des prescriptions d'articles qui
vont tous dans le même sens et qui vous
conforte tous les jours dans le choix
qui est le vôtre si vous êtes sensibles
par exemple sur la question des animaux
on va vous mettre quelque chose 13 en
amorce enfin pour un hameçonnage sur la
problématique des agneaux et puis petit
à petit on va emballer ça et au final
vous allez avoir c'est celui qui est oui
et donc et à la fin c'est en gros on va
conforter votre choix politique parce
que l'autre camp c'est ça c'est sans les
publicités politiques dont on imagine
que à la fois les entreprises nous
disent on va lutter contre l'effet que
nous mais en même temps elles vont
accepter des publicités politiques qui
sont encore un degré au delà dans ce qui
est j'allais dire le côté bien gros bien
grossier bien fait que les articles qui
sont véhiculés donc on a un vrai sujet
sur comment on fabrique aujourd'hui
l'opinion et comment les démocraties
doivent répondre à cette nouvelle
fabrique de l'opinion via les réseaux
sociaux
et je pense qu'on n'y est pas donc que
déjà on met les publicités politiques
c'est peut-être ça mais c'est déjà un
premier pas moi ce que je vois c'est que
ça fait quand même plusieurs années
qu'on essaie avec facebook et son patron
d'avoir des réponses à la fois au niveau
national au niveau européen où il va à
chaque fois il arrive je trouve qu'il ne
prépare rien ils sont fous en fait un
son audition en europe avait déjà été un
peu du même genre là franchement les
questions de la députée sont pas d'une
virulence extrême elle son pointu mais
ça va on voit que oui mais c'est pas
exactement ça et ça passe face à un
moment donné je ne sais pas mais moi je
pense faut arrêter notamment sénatrice
américaine qui fait beaucoup pour le
démantèlement des gaffes h c'est parce
qu'on sait bien qui sort de tout ça
c'est que c'est ces entreprises là sont
supérieurs à tous points de vue aux
états avec qui ne l'entendent répond à
personne il dirige le monde ya leur
façon et ce qui m'inquiète encore plus
est puisque j'en ai j'en faisais partie
c'est comment nous les médias
traditionnels nous pouvons survivre à ce
type d'information
comment est ce que nous pourrions le
faire alors on est mal parti pour le
faire aussi pour une autre raison c'est
que même en tant que média traditionnels
les stations d'information en continu
s'ils ont besoin
si je puis me permettre cette expression
de gasoil toute la journée pour
fonctionner
vont faire d'un épiphénomène un
phénomène comme disait ma maman d'une
clause cerise ils font un clafoutis on
va être quatre à attendre l'autobus d'or
parce qu'il incarne un certain ça
devienne une manifestation s'est même
les mots même les mots cigare au même
même les mots sont exagérées 100
personnes devant l'assemblée nationale
je joue aujourd'hui manifestation non
attroupement dont il ya tout un
vocabulaire peut être que nous les
médias tradition se prenait vraiment
main on pourrait aileron serait écoutée
par ces gens qui écoutent sur sur l'île
afin d informations sur internet et nous
nous pourrions être en réaction à sa et
au moins il y aurait un côté ayez
l'autre côté moins de 10 ans était
constamment une problématique c'est que
les gars pas diffuse nos contenus
payants c'est laisser les tchèques nous
ce qu'on fait pas mal de aujourd'hui
deux sites d'info on les a dans
plusieurs puisqu'ils sont de vérifier et
de contrôler et d'argumenter sur des sur
une partie d'un faux et je pense que
cette fonction là aujourd'hui elle est
remplie principalement par les médias
dits traditionnels et qu'elle est hyper
utile pour ne pas s'enflammer
le france télévisions à une france aux
médias français ont régulièrement
plusieurs fois par jour je pense qu'il
est avec l'efficace et il devient de
fait avec news et ça c'est bien le
développer
parce que ça c'est un moyen peut-être
peut-être oui la base du métier parce
qu'en plus ce système là fonctionne non
plus sur le raisonnement mais sur
émotions réaction donc émotions réaction
c'est terrifiant souligné tout cela
forme là l'importance de l'information
de qualité et donc des médias
traditionnels et que malgré tout le
cette sortie jack dorsey a le mérite de
montrer du doigt
les distorsions des gaffes à